[Music]
joining me today is a commentator and
YouTube creator who has been called the
king of controversy and someone who as
of this moment has been suspended by the
Twitter
Tommy Sotomayor welcome to the Rubin
report well thank you Dave all right I
guess we're gonna have to do this in
over 140 characters you're off the
Twitter yeah
it's harmful is hurtful it's sad I don't
know if I'll be able to make it till
tomorrow but all right so we are gonna
do this in long-form that more than 140
characters we'll see if we can do it so
now we're taping this probably about a
week before it's gonna air roughly so
there's a chance you're back on Twitter
by the time this has happened we don't
know what did you do to get kicked off
the king of controversy what did you do
it must be your fault apparently what I
did was respond to people who were
talking to me or just sent out videos on
my own Twitter timeline that the only
way you should see it is if you either
follow me or someone that follows you
retweet now apparently that's something
that makes people really sad about their
day and it hurts them and they can't
have their coffee in the morning and the
kids go to school you know like Van
Jones said that the kids are at
breakfast and don't know what to expect
afterwards yeah so they had to get rid
of me in order to make those people's
lives better I don't really know that
the story that I got from Twitter was
this simply I was making it a harassing
place for other Twitter users which
makes no sense because I don't really
mess with other people they mess with me
yeah so just to be clear you're not out
there hunting down people and picking
fights and all that stuff you're
responding to people who are going there
for you now in the most cases you have
more of a following than them so somehow
that then tricks people to think that
you're the bully here but that wouldn't
be your take on it no and it's like the
biggest thing is YouTube does not
protect not YouTube but our Twitter
doesn't protect the content creators if
you do have that type of following that
means that you're generating traffic for
them that every time you say something
people want to see what you say people
want to retweet what you say they want
to watch what you post but instead
they're allowing the small people the
trolls to have the most power because
you can just poke the bear then the bear
turns around and pulls his claws out
your zookeeper comes in shoo
damn right so pairs like what about what
am I supposed to do right bears going
you let the kid in the cage but but your
bigger bear so you should understand and
in life a lot of what we're doing is
saying there's a group of society
that's supposed to have more common
sense and morality than another group
the other group can just run wild and we
must protect them and I think that's one
of the biggest problems we have with
social media and American general yeah
so that relates to a lot of the stuff
that you do videos about but before we
get to that for people who have no idea
who you are but there might be one or
two people out there that don't know you
for those people who are you what what
made you get into this game of being
public about what you what you think I
grew up in an atmosphere of where I
realized that having a single mom no man
around was the norm but as I grew up I
also started to understand a lot of the
children from those environments did not
do well they didn't do well in life they
didn't do well in relationships they
didn't do well in parenting they just
didn't do well because they couldn't
function because they didn't see the
dynamic of two people trying to make
something happen because if you think
about it in a single-parent household
the person who's the single parent is a
dictator if they just don't want you to
learn math you won't learn math one of
the greatest movies I love that
addresses this is the waterboy mm-hmm
the waterboy had a single mom who
decided to be lord over his life and
wouldn't let him learn anything and and
wanted to basically ruin his life
now she woke up at the end but the whole
part was well we got rid of the father
and we don't need the father there's too
many places out there where people say
they don't need the father so I wanted
to address that because fathers rights
in America are none like no one cares
that a fathers put in jail for paying
for not paying child support but the
woman can have a credit score of 200 so
she owes everyone but she doesn't go to
jail for it but this guy who may have
not wanted the child in the first place
when the woman gets the option to have a
child I just wanted to address a lot of
things on from a man's standpoint that a
lot of people want address yeah all
right so let's pause on men's right for
just a second water boy would you say
that was Adam Sandler's last good movie
because these last couple have been
pretty frickin horrible they have this
I bar but can you admit that they have
been and the sad part was it is that
it's watching him because you grew up
with him and he's so funny and now
you're trying to convince people he's
still funny and it's just not it's like
the last Metallica album you really
wanted to get behind but you realize it
wasn't good you're just a fan there's
something there about like just becoming
a victim of your own success right
because those first Adam Sandler movies
I mean to me Billy Madison is almost a
perfect comedy for the time it came out
in and then a couple after that but
after water boy these Netflix things
yeah and then he did the little Nikki
that wasn't aimed in Spanglish was his
trying to get into yeah it's like nobody
took him seriously though and then that
last few things he's done it's just it's
sad to watch yeah alright moving past
Adam Sam thank you probably do an hour
on just Adam salmon yes but putting that
aside so when did you actually wake up
to that because that's a pretty powerful
thing you're saying you came from a
household where your mom was your mom
was the dictator so to speak were you
twelve when you saw what was going on
there it was this later into adulthood
well here's a funny thing it's like um
I'd say like the movie frequency where
the guy had two memories he had one of
where his father died he had one of
where's father was alive because he was
the only one that noticed that both
happened everybody else's life had
changed well it's the same thing when
you're growing up in a neighborhood
where everyone else has a mom which is a
dictator and it's a norm when you watch
the news right now or watch the NBA
Draft you will see some black guy get up
there and he'll say thanks to my mom
it'll be a bunch of women stand up and
it will be no dad his first thing that I
asked him wasn't gonna do what all his
money is I'm gonna take care of my mom
and buy my mom my house now you never
had to hear peyton manning say this
because peyton manning had this thing
called a father his father bought his
mom a house a lot of black children the
males become the breadwinner that's why
you see so many young men out on the
streets selling drugs because they're
trying to take care of him be the man
that mom couldn't pick when he or she
was had and it's a sad dynamic and what
happened with me was over time i started
to hang around other people who had
their fathers i got lucky that we went
from a bad neighborhood to middle-class
and all of my white friends had their
fathers when we graduated they would
have their whole family
a few black people I went to the high
school I went to they all just had their
mom there on and then I noticed a lot of
my white friends went on to be married a
lot of my black friends went on to
repeat the cycle
we have children we're not in the lives
of the children we have multiple mothers
we end up in jail
we end up with criminal records we end
up just not knowing how to survive in
society and I think probably when I was
thirty I said some somebody has to say
something because this is ridiculous
like nobody's pointing it out but in one
side of me it was saying but this is
normal if you say this even my mom said
well you're saying this and then you're
trying to make me look bad and I thought
but it's what happened I don't
understand how we don't want to stop
this cycle from repeating itself by
having silence it's the equivalent of
having a molester in the house nobody
wants to say we have a molester in the
house because it'll make us look bad to
the other people in the neighborhood or
the community so the molester keeps to
go around it keeps it keeps going out
and molesting people and victimizing
people and the victims are the ones who
have to be quiet to protect this
so-called image that was never there in
the first place
yeah how difficult is this stuff to talk
about I've done a little bit on men's
rights on the show and I've had Cass EJ
who did the red pill movie and a couple
other people Karen's drawn on I come
from a family my parents been married
over 40 years and I do I don't think
until the last few years I realized how
actually important that is when I now
since I grew up in New York I moved away
now when I go home and I go home still
to the same home that I grew up in the
same community the friends that they've
had for 30 40 years kids that I was five
years old with that it now have kids
themselves and all that stuff that that
that root has meaning but it's really
hard to talk about this stuff right like
when people I you see people bring this
up on TV and people make it seem like
it's about race and it's not about race
mm-hmm I don't think and I suspect you
don't think so either but but even for
you as a black man you're black is that
yeah that's but really you don't mean
like even for you to talk about it it it
feels like there's a racial component
but you haven't said anything racial
really you're just talking about the
fact of what you saw yeah and it
is difficult to talk about because it
affects the black community so much so
that when you speak of it they look at
you and they said well you're condemning
black people well in essence I am if you
pull back the layers because that's the
side that I know because like you said
your father and mom married 40 years and
you've been able to see stability well
most of my friends have it most of my
friends are like myself I'm 41 years old
I wake up every day and I'm trying to
figure out how to be a man
at 41 because I'd never saw one I never
saw how a man is supposed to be a father
I never saw how a man supposed to be a
husband I just saw a female dictator and
the female dictator could do no wrong
one of the biggest problems that I think
when you have these women especially
when they're violent because I grew up
in a violent household the women in our
community believe in violence towards
their children that's the way to keep
him out of jail which doesn't work but
it's believed there was a woman a mother
in Baltimore and they called her the
riot mom I don't know if you remember
when her son was out there with a mask
on and she came and grabbed at me oh
yeah yeah and all the white liberals
were talking about how great this was
and I said how is that great if this had
been any parent from any other race they
would have thought that's abuse first
off why is your child out there yeah
that's something you should have known
number two the mother was out there with
the child she just happened to see the
child number three the woman has six
children she lives in a bad neighborhood
and she has six kids by six different
dudes but nobody wanted to address any
of this she's a good mom cuz she's on
him if she was really a good mom one of
the most important things a woman can do
is pick the correct person to have the
kid with so we're allowing these women
to just have kids with do to her in and
out of jail do to don't have jobs but
the only person that's being held
responsible is the guy cuz well you
didn't have a job when you had them
living in your house and you let him
impregnate you
but now that you've got fallen out let's
put him on child support even though he
didn't have a job in the first place cuz
you were supporting it and then that
just perpetuates more poverty more
inability to get a good job and you you
can sort of never get ahead so if you
scale all this stuff back what do you
think is the fault for this
where did this happen to the black
family because it always it wasn't
always like this so where do you go how
far do you have to go back to start
making sense of how it got to this place
Great Society and LBJ because right
before the Great Society and LBJ black
people as far as couples and families
kids born in wedlock I think it was 92
percent and around the early 60s it
dropped in the 70s to around 50 percent
and now only twenty four percent of
black children are born in what and
whether the number is astounding and
then look at right there where they
thought started telling black women well
if you work with the state if you have
children and there's no man there will
compensate you I think one of the
craziest things that we have right now
is we help families less than we help
single moms so what you're doing if you
have a child so if you have four kids if
you have one who you pay the most
attention to because they're getting
into dirt and the one that's a
straight-a student you decide they know
what they're doing
well the straight-a student will start
to become a little jealous because
you're not paying them as much attention
so they'll start to degrade to become
closer to that when they get your
attention imagine if you're doing that
with black single moms they're getting
money they're getting places to stay I
don't know if you saw the black woman
who said I got 15 kids and somebody are
gonna help me take care of these kids
and actually bought her a house a month
later cuz he got on the news yeah saying
somebody's gonna help me take care of
these kids that I lay down and God
because I'm a woman and it's my body I
can do what I want to with it but once I
do it I need help and that's what
bothers me because men don't get a
chance to do that men don't get a chance
to say it's my body I can do what I want
to but when I get in trouble I'm gonna
need you to help me out how much of this
is just compounded by white liberal
guilt do you think cuz this is something
I talked about that that liberals have
gone crazy
I would argue it's mostly it's really
progressives on the left not what true
liberals are but that liberal guilt in
general just enables this stuff that
because we're so afraid to talk about
anything because it will come off as
racist or bigoted or any of that stuff
but we just perpetuate this cycle mm-hmm
well meeting people you know what I mean
I don't think they're bad people
that's the most important but I don't
think for the most part they're there
there are people of course who have bad
intentions but I think for the most part
they don't and they're doing something
bad I think the people in power have bad
intentions I got the people that follow
see a magnanimous behavior and it looks
like a good thing yes we owe these
people and I started a movement called
guiltless I wanted white people to stop
feeling bad because when you look at
something like it bombings it barn X was
a white person saying well they'll never
get English so we'll just say that what
they're speaking is a normal language so
they can continue to speak it meanwhile
you have Hosea Paco whose family just
ran across the Rio Grande ten years ago
yeah speaking perfect English there is
no reason for us to have the issue if
we've been here in America since pretty
much the white people were here we've
been at the same time so the certain
point in time you have to view your
shortcomings by what haven't you done
because we can't hold anybody hostage to
what they did in the past you I don't
know one white person who's personally
benefited from owning my ancestors who
were slaves I don't know this person now
if it is then I'll ask him for the money
they all look in your past what because
of that beast we're all from the
Northeast but because of that we have to
start saying okay where are we gonna
level the playing field now everybody
just starts here yeah cuz that's true
equality but right now black people
because of liberals we're not asking for
equality we're just asking for handouts
we're saying we deserve it even though
the people who fought died and marched
for it would not want this this is not
what they were asking for dr. Martin
Luther King was not asking for a handout
he was just asking for the opportunity
to be treated as an equal citizen yeah
and right now that's not what you're
getting when you see a fire department
have to hire three blacks even though
the three blacks have a lower test score
than the other whites because we have to
meet a quota yeah and it in some ways
that then also degrades the services
right because if you're allowing people
in whether it's a fire department or
school or medical school whatever it
might be if you're letting people in
with lower grades because
of race it doesn't have to be just black
whatever the race is well you're
actually causing people that are less
qualified to be at certain things and
then the services the actual operation
you might get have you been through TSA
in Atlanta I was there yeah the you see
the Jagger gay I got you whether you'll
see the degradation of service and it's
true you go somewhere and the government
black women makeup I think it's seven
percent or six percent six to seven
percent of society in government they
make up around ten percent of the jobs
why is that then they put them in these
jobs we can't get rid of them and no
most of time you go to these places
you're getting a horrible service and
and to to look at black society right
now that it's a foregone conclusion that
all racists believe if you have a black
server at a restaurant you're gonna get
bad service now that's just a thought
that you think of but you look at other
communities you think of Jews will say
well my kids are gonna grow up to be a
doctor or lawyer well as black people
what we're telling our kids to grow up
to be into entertainment to grow up to
be a football player which is less than
1% of society can do this thing but
you're telling your kids the only way
out is this way so what happened to the
educated black what happened to going to
school and getting your education even
at the end of the waterboard you listen
to what he said when he was supposed to
be going pro he said no no I'm gonna go
and get my degree first and these are
things that are missing in our community
because I can't remember the last person
who said your degree matters when I got
when I told my mom I was accepted to
college she told me that's great I don't
know how you're gonna pay for so for 18
years hmm she didn't collect $10 a year
$15 e or something to sin and that's my
story is the story of the majority of
black children we go to college and it's
like figure it out if you go and I've
seen black children get discouraged by
their parents to not go because they're
like well I can't help you pay for it
and if you look at what white liberals
do they're continuing to tell these
mothers who are producing these children
in bad environments like the black
mother in Chicago who had five of her
sons all five of her sons were murdered
in the same neighborhood they did a host
worried about her and they were
boo-hooing and saying how horrible it
was for her but wait a minute she knew
she lived in basically chiraq she knew
that was a bad neighborhood she knew it
was dangerous for boys after the first
Dave if I'm the first one of your
children got killed in the neighborhood
what would you do
yeah you get moving move yeah and she
stayed there long enough for four more
to be killed and white liberals don't
stand up and say well that's
irresponsible they'll say oh it's
because they're those poor blacks they
don't have any money and we just need to
throw more money at them well no you
don't you need to throw responsibility
towards them you need to say wait a
minute if you are a woman and you're
looking at the world and saying my body
I can do what I want well once you
started having all these kids with all
these people who couldn't afford to take
care of them nor could you we're not
gonna help either why do we not have a
system that says if you have one child
and you're on government assistance you
cannot have another why is that
considered wrong you know I mean I think
there's issues related to personal
freedoms and all that and what the
government gives out but I the the basic
idea of what you're saying I get there
I'm you know you mentioned something
interesting about that what the black
community's doing is saying you know we
should win Emmys or you know be in
entertainment or in sports or that kind
of thing and you know there was that
whole Oscars so white thing I had on
Reva Martin who was actually for you
know diversifying the Oscars more and
then I had Larry elder who I suspect you
probably agree with a lot more saying
how ridiculous it was but to me it's
like just at winning more Oscars or more
Emmys or having more people in sorts has
nothing to do with success there's a
reason why Chinese Americans and Indian
Americans meeting people from India not
Native Americans they don't care about
that stuff and they don't protest it
because they are busting their asses in
school and that has to come from the
home and so their eyes basically their
eyes are on the right price not the
prize that the Liberals want you to
think is the right prize if only we had
the exact amount of people winning
Oscars everything would be equal but
this is this is a really hard thing to
extricate from society which doesn't
make sense cuz it's the same amount of
people who are black we're winning a
Wars just like white people white people
should complain because white people
have more people in
United States so the numbers wouldn't
bear it out why would only 30 white
people should complain about the NBA I'd
get tired to be in the NBA I get tired
of being a white guy turn on this
television with my two white sons and
we're watching all these black guys
running up and down and my kids thinking
I can't be that yeah how fair is that
now had this been the NBA and had been
once a bunch of white people black
people said well they're keeping black
people out because they just don't want
us in there but when we're over running
it we're like yeah that's cuz we're
better than you yeah if we want all the
Oscars there would be no black people
saying well that's kind of messed up
that no white people want when we'd be
like yeah cuz we're better than trust me
my hero is right there Clyde Drexler 80s
90s basketball star I wanted to be him I
realized the skill set was not there to
go ahead and be quiet
[Music]
you